- How are you doing?
JARED: Good, how are you?
I'm pretty good.
JARED: I've got something I
think you'll be interested in.
"From Russia with Love," huh?
JARED: Well, that
gun that Sean Connery
held in the promotional shots--
Oh, wow.
You mind if I check it out?
JARED: Sure.
It's pretty cool, man.
What do you think?
JARED: I think you
need to wear a tux.
Yeah, I don't wear tuxes, man.
[laughter]
JARED: I have owned
this Walther pellet
gun for about nine years.
A friend of mine
that passed away,
actually, was the owner of
it, and he left it to me.
Walther makes other guns,
but this, I understand,
was the first pellet
gun they ever made.
I'm trying to get $500
for my Walther pellet gun,
and I've kind of decided
that's the least I would take
would be $300.
Yeah, this is a pretty
interesting story, actually.
Sean Connery went to
the promotional shoots
for "From Russia with Love,"
and they didn't have the gun
he was supposed to shoot with.
So by chance, I guess the
photographer happened to have
this Walther in his car.
So he went and got
it and thus, became
the famous picture that
everyone knows from the movie.
It's pretty cool, man.
What do you know about it?
JARED: Well, they've resold
the one that Sean Connery
used twice that I found.
- OK.
JARED: Once about
10 years ago or so,
for over a half million dollars.
And they resold it last year
again for about $200,000.
So I wasn't looking for
quite that much, but--
Yeah, I hope you're
not, because I'm
going to send you on your way.
[laughter]
Pretty much everybody
knows about James Bond.
And I know a lot of people
think Sean Connery was one
of the best bonds
of the franchise,
but we're not looking
at the golden gun here.
And even though
this one is cool,
it's not the one that
was used in the movie.
So how much do you want for it?
JARED: I'd like to
get $500 for it.
[sighs]
Oh, man.
I don't know.
JARED: I think it's worth $500.
They're pretty rare.
The thing is, I just don't
think people are out there
collecting this
pistol, or they would
just be on the market more.
I'm looking more like $150.
Oh, I couldn't go that low.
I could come down to $400.
I'm going [inaudible]
my best offer at $200.
I would sell it
today for $250,
but I can't sell it
for any less than that.
For $200, I'd love it, but
for $250, it's just not right.
I understand.
All right.
JARED: Thank you.
See ya later.
JARED: I'm not
bothered a whole lot.
If I can't get $250
for it, I'll just
try to sell it
myself someplace else
because I think I
can get the money.